good morning believe nation today's
message is trust yourself over to you
Selena Gomez and when I was 11 I had a
casting director tell me that I wasn't
strong enough to carry my own show and
I'm sure all of you have been told that
you don't have what it takes and that
you may not be good enough and you don't
have enough people supporting you and
you're being told all of these things
when deep down it's all you want to do
you want to be a part of something great
you want to make something great and it
does more than knock the wind out of you
it crushes you when people tried to tell
you that you're not good enough and it
almost did for me but there was my mom
next to me stronger than ever and she
said the most important thing is to
always trust in myself if I have if I'm
doing something because I love it I
should do it because I love it and I
believe I can do it so she told me to
keep going
she told me and she taught me to turn
the other cheek and let the credits are
in like the critics be critics and let
us just trust ourselves so for me two
years later I got my own show and the
first thought the first thought wasn't
oh man
that girl when I was 11 said I wouldn't
carry my own show and I did I mean I
thought about that for a little bit but
I thought about what my mom said my mom
was like you have to trust yourself and
I realized if I didn't believe that I
could do it I wouldn't be able to be
here I think one of the biggest issues
for people in trust in themselves is
having a supportive environment that
helps you do something big because
everybody wakes up at some point and has
this big idea that they want to go off
and chase right I mean you wake up in
your bowl right now I'm gonna go and do
this this is my goal for this year or
this week here's when I go out and do
I'm gonna show them get this big idea
and then life hits you in the face and
says no you're not gonna do that
and all these roadblocks come up and
that's where most people quit they take
their shot you know the I tried I gave
it my best shot it didn't work out I'm
done we're for Selena Gomez it's her mom
saying trust yourself
don't don't care about what the critics
said about you you can do what I believe
in you right she had that support system
what do you do when you don't have that
support system you know I was lucky
growing up that my parents always told
me that I was a ghost Rudy Carmichael my
mom's last name is kiss really and I
could do anything when I was getting
poor grades in school I had to sit down
with them every semester look at my
report card they didn't chastise me they
didn't get angry at me they always told
me that I was a ghost really Carmichael
I could do anything and that's where
believe came from believe was my parents
and even though they couldn't really
give me business advice on how to build
a company the foundational value helped
me but now a big part of it is is the
this YouTube channel right is is a
top-ten City
since presto series right if you don't
have friends or family around you to
support your borsa but if there's a
little man right up there the people who
are telling you why you can't get it
done then what you do the answer isn't
well I don't have a good family so I'm
going to quit you know that's that's
passing the buck that's that's placing
responsibilities and other people you're
responsible for your own life the reason
why you're not successful is not because
of your parents or your country or you
know if you're a man or a woman or if
you have a disability or not or you know
what color your skin is none of that
matters that's not why you're not
successful you're not successful because
of you and your mindset and as long as
you start blaming other people as long
as you are blaming external factors for
the reason why you're not successful
then you're never going to change and
you're never going to be successful
having that environment is important if
you don't have it now it's not your
parents fault it's your fault go out and
build it read books that make you come
alive and stretch yourself watch a top
10 series Indians wrestle series and the
other videos in this channel to be
surrounded by great entrepreneurs who
are doing great things that make you
believe we can do more go and find the
new circle of friends people who inspire
you and push you to want to go and do
more create the environment for yourself
to help you develop the confidence to
trust in yourself when the next big bold
idea comes around that life tells you
that you can't do you get back up and
you hit it out because you trust
yourself
so the question thing today is I want to
know what you do when you doubt yourself
what do you do how do you get out of
that rut leave in the comments below
really curse see what you guys say I'd
also really appreciate it I'm trying to
get to a million subscribers in this
channel so if you can share out of the
playlist help you about this video it
means a lot to me thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
a vinspresso
Oh wakes up an espresso give me go